[Music]
hi thank you thanks a lot everybody I'm
bald I don't know if you know that about
me I'm actually balding I like to say
balding it sounds more productive it's
like I'm always up to something I don't
say I'm losing my hair that that makes
it sound like I've been more responsible
this wouldn't have happened like where's
your hair I lost it
oh you don't mean I got I'm excited a
new pickup line that I'm using on the
ladies when I go to dive bars it's uh so
what's a girl like you doing in a place
like this pretty good way better than
the line I used to use which is uh it
makes perfect sense that you would be
here I mean I I suck at handshakes right
screw them up all the time
I never know which way I'm gonna screw
it up next time like recently I was a
bar I saw someone that I knew as a bar I
wanted to greet him and he was to the
opposite end of the room right so
immediately I felt like walking over
towards him right to see you as soon as
I started walking that's when he saw me
and our eyes met right and I freaked out
that's when I
I pulled my hand out like way too soon
like I had a long way to go it was about
halfway there I realized if if you pull
your hand out just soon you kind of just
have to keep it out of there
you guys just pretend like this is not
weird to me it's how I do it and the
worst part was there was like one moment
during the long walk when for some
reason I thought it would alleviate some
of the tension if I said here I come I
want to get up it was like five years
ago I wanted like a job job of this
summer right so so I heard about this
job at the Mall of America I live in
Minneapolis I say there's his job kids
are not allowed to be at the Mall of
America without an adult right so
there's a job or someone they walk
around the mall they ID kids if they're
underage you take him home they get sent
home I don't know how they get home
whatever a job so I heard about this so
I called the HR department at the Mall
of America and I got a voicemail and I
got all tongue-tied that's I said I go
hi my name is Isaac witty and I'm
interested in that job where you walk
around the mall and find kids and take
them home
[Applause]
write this down the men's day at all
this weight came out I tried to correct
myself but I think in the process I
sounded even creepier like I said all
that and then there's like a long pause
and I said to their home
oh my god I don't I don't want kids in
my house
so give me a call comedy's weird man you
can't always do comedy and ideal
situations right like sometimes you
gotta do shows her heart right yeah I
didn't show one time is for some company
and I didn't know what the company did
right so I went up somebody before the
show and I was like what does he you
guys do right he said oh it's
commodities right you guys we buy and
sell corn and green beans right I don't
even know what that means
but apparently there's a business I
guess root what do you just call people
there's that guy hey what's going on so
do you you know buy some green beans
know your well that's fine huh huh they
can't see us every time I'm in will get
talking to you anyway I'm gonna let you
go yo what what one more question before
I do let you go um do do do you have any
green beans that I could buy
[Applause]